just gonna win place it with our [ __ ]
hood we're gonna be giving the category
we gotta start one big one and cut one
I'm gonna start fried my life will come
on dog movie I'll move [ __ ] Remember
the Titans and I'm a current Rudy all
right so we go get Rudy there so I'm
ready to go I'm ready to start over to
Tiny's though and then I'm gonna start
grab the bottle of course then I'm gonna
[ __ ] call of duty
I'm like a good man almost start to
leverage it Vince
super strength and I'm okay super speed
what he what everybody I'm gonna go with
this I'm gonna start the seven-layer dip
I'm being on buffalo chicken dip on so
but I'm I start down i'ma cut peaceful I
can't and I'm a [ __ ] wing but cut the
pieces good wait he's a buffalo chicken
today I'm a chicken person you feel
peace aside on a piece of her men are my
people right you're saying home offense
Queens I love wings and people that I
got the best wings also and I'm
definitely couldn't beat it dude oh dude
Carter three started listen because of
three you money to call me
Lil Wayne vitatree we shiny young money
yeah nobody else matters
Wayne to go well I are a [ __ ] I bent
the blueprint and rich that's Ryan Davis
are they my generation winner wins and
it's away and we will American Cancer
Society please go to cancel that order
to donate the critical cage